comme chaque fin d'année le concours
miss france et bientôt de retour avec
son lot de discours de défilés et de
paillettes mais depuis sa création le
concours at il vraiment changé
absolument c'est le contraire de ce
qu'on faisait six projets njawe de fonte
et on le sait plus rien ne va certains
trouvent que ce concours n'est plus en
phase avec notre époque le concours des
miss est effectivement fondamentalement
sexiste tout d'abord pour l'image qu'il
reflète de la femme une conception de la
féminité assez patriarcal qui n'a pour
but de mettre en valeur que leur
physique elles ont la liberté de le
faire si elles le font c'est qu'elles
ont acceptées autre point qu'on ne se le
cache pas si on est souvent si l'ombre
devant le programme c'est surtout pour
critiquer se moquer d'une miss qui va
chuter ou bafouiller car il faut le
reconnaître on adore ça vous vous
demandez sûrement mais hélas cela
enfin les règles pour accéder au
concours et c'est sur ce point que s'est
exprimée la ministre déléguée à
l'égalité femmes-hommes elisabeth moreno
ce qui m'interroge ce sont les règles
que je trouve complètement à venir un
concours qui mériterait peut-être bien
d'être dépoussiéré un peu alors le
concours miss france est il devenu
ringard
c'est vrai que voilà alors il ya ça ça
fait toujours parler un le concours des
miss ans et ça y est les miss se sont ça
y est on a toutes les miss sélectionnées
alors il ya un truc que chaque année un
des moments les plus attendus du
concours c'est le défilé en maillot de
bain et c'est aussi un des moments les
plus critiqués parce qu'ils jugent le
concours sexistes ou ringard on va
revoir celui de l'an dernier me dire ce
que l'on pense et des films vous avez
défini mais le bambou j'avais défilé en
maillot de bain deux pièces de placer
une pièce aussi avait pas de souci ça
m'a pas traumatisé et et sestrière c'est
magnifique ce concours ça permet aux
gens de rêver devant leur télé et puis
surtout ça donne après une carrière aux
jeunes filles ça leur permet d'avoir
confiance en elle prendre confiance
c'est une expérience guillaume vous êtes
fier de delphine que définie
pour moi merci merci vous attend la
passe d un masque pas dépasser dès que
je fais tout l'été ce n'est pas des
[ __ ] c'était city cité des penaltys est
ce qu'elle est ce que tu as regardé mon
élection guillaume parent garde tous les
jours en boucle
regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors est ce que ça vous dérange la boue
parce que c'est ça c'est ça le plus
dérangeant c'est ce moment là delphine
madame qu'elle tombait des nues
et me kelly est ce que vous ça vous
dérange pas et pas du tout en fait moi
j'ai répondu oui parce que oui c'est
ringard on adore ce soir un gars je ne
veux pas que ce soit autrement en fait
moi j'adore j'adore rêver j'adore les
voir tous de belles j'adore les voir
marcher la danse gym auxi regarder c'est
ce que vous aimez dans le concours ouais
c'est ce que j'aime c'est ce que j'aime
si c'était pas un regard ce serait
différent et nous on veut chaque année
la même chose on veut ça on veut le
spiral axé leur attaquant d'année sous
peu oui alors attendez guillaume genton
et et énervé il ya un autre moment fort
de la cérémonie mais jugé très ringard
par beaucoup c'est le défilé en costumes
régionaux ça c'est ça qui est je vais
revoir un extrait regardez vous avez
fait vous l'aviez fait oui j'ai très
fier de porter pour la première fois
mais au raid alsacienne et où j'ai gardé
après ils du coup je suis belge il les a
gardés tout en lui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors d'accord dompter journal des
régions trouve que c'est génial et là
comme par hasard un gars ça vous énerve
quand on dit que l'escale a dit la
ministre on vient là dessus des
ministres a dit que con qu ils feront
c'était ringard mais vivre dans
l'égalité femmes hommes il y avait un
gars vivent le has been vive le qui ça
vous énerve à nice alors un gars de
quelqu'un mais vous savez patrick
sébastien on l'a trouvée ringard on l'a
jeté 1 alors que ça cartonnait que les
gens adorent comme toujours nous y voilà
donc arrêtons arrêtons quand même de
décider pour les gens ce qui est de bon
goût de mauvais goût le bon côté le
mauvais côté on adore laissions les
force pas participer à miss france elles
sont super contents comme l'admr vote
jamais c'est génial c'est ça aurait pu
participer à miss france me bats je
crois pas quand même monsieur nous
enfin quand j'étais très jeune vous ça
vous aurait pu
ouais j'ai pas pensé pour la région
midi-pyrénées bonne comme vous voulez me
fait jouer
alors chaque année les mises passe par
un moment très stressant les fameuses
questions de jean-pierre et pour
certaines c'est un enfer on se souvient
notamment de miss côte d'azur qui avait
appris par coeur son texte à pauvres peu
importe la question elle était dans son
bail
mais n'obéit à aucune raison de l'être
dites moi qu'est ce que vous faites dans
la vie ou que vous devez vous faire
comme la france est un carrefour
historique un trait d'union sud et nord
je suis le fruit de la rencontre entre
l'angleterre et l'italie je suis fier
d'être métis européenne et de parler
couramment la langue de shakespeare est
différente et je fais des études en
langues étrangères appliquées suite à
mon diplôme je souhaite intégrer une
école de théâtre à paris je suis
passionné par le monde du spectacle de
la mode et de la photographie
je m'appelle charles à 2000 j'ai 19 ans
et je représente la côte d'azur je me
fais dire quelque chose je suis fier
qu'aux machines nice accueille le
téléthon cette année donc s'il vous
plaît mobilisez-vous massis s'est
inquiétée
elle était
vous avez ou pas sur les discours c'est
souvent là que se fait la bascule oui
oui c'est une élection de jolies
gonzesses mais en fait c'est aussi les
gens qui vous qui votent pour la miss
ils ont envie d'une bise qui sache
parler qui est habileté voilà et et
aurait du mal à l aller
alors il ya eu un discours tout
d'histoire vous montrer cette en 2015 la
miss était tellement stressée qu'elle en
perd ses mots là pour vous ça vous ça a
été moi ça a été très bien j'ai fait une
tirade de trois minutes 50 je crois ah
ouais et vous la péter pace
à part ça ça va et à chaque fois qu'il
ya des reprises comme ça en fait on me
montre comme le discours le plus long du
truc des miss ah ouais ça vous avez fait
le discours mais j'en ai besoin de tout
j'avais tout besoin de montrer donc j'ai
fait un truc de ouf c'est comme dire
quand vous allez voir une fois
il va tout mais il va tout montrer en
une sur le toit batum autres étaient
partis regarder
c'est un accélérateur de vie je pense
que durant une année de miss france
c'est serait pas capable de pouvoir
vivre ce qu'on serait capable de vivre
vous inquiétez pas on joue seul dans le
désert
ouais alors ça ça c'était ça c'était
fois alors rien et un truc qui revient
souvent on dit que pour ce soit moins
ringard ya beaucoup de gens qui disent
aussi qu'il faudrait accepter les miss
transgenres c'est déjà le cas en espagne
puisqu'il ya déjà des pays qui ont
ouvert le concours de miss aux candidats
transsexuels ou quand voilà en espagne
angela pons né en ukraine mario ponce
camacho en 91 est devenue miss espagne
2018 ça mais c'est vrai que c'est pas
une balade label regarder bas on va le
voir garder l'amitié au gars gardez pas
ça c'était lui mais c'était bien lui
c'était voilà c'était elle elle et
c'était aux lions s'étaient angel s'est
passé en djellaba regarder
[Applaudissements]
est ce que
parce que yahia team italien qui a dit
le règlement miss france est simple il
faut être une femme entre 18 et 25 ans
pour concourir demain si une femme ou un
garçon ayant chaud les deux sexes ayant
donc un état civil féminin se présente
au concours miss france nous ne sommes
pas la police je ne vais pas lui faire
passer une visite médicale donc ça
pourrait être possible parce que ce
serait bien gilles verdez c'est une
évolution nécessaire et il va y en avoir
alexia laroche joubert a été nommé à la
tête de miss france elle va changer des
choses on a enquêté avec bernard et
c'est vrai que sylvie t la ligue en a
vraiment qui bien manger des enquêteurs
comme ça s'est inversé
on va vous dire voilà tête des
enquêteurs
c'est pourquoi
aux autres candidats avec quelque part
bien on vient pour ôter
ses montées trop qu'il a eue si le
propriétaire on est tranquille alors on
va brûler notre infographie sache pas
mal d'amazing fait que sylvie tellier va
être écarté petit à petit
alexia laroche joubert va changer elle
est là pour changer rapprocher mises des
français s'est scala di des règles vont
évoluer ça va changer un peu donc moi je
trouve pas que c'est ringard et ça va
aller dans un sens positif avec une
acceptation de plus en plus de gens donc
je suis très content mais oui c'est
complètement hypocrite ce qu'a dit parce
que techniquement aujourd'hui les femmes
transgenres peuvent déjà se présenter
parce qu'il faut être né de sexe féminin
alors qu'on sait qu'en réalité vous
verrez jamais une femme transgenre dans
mischka n'ont pas été sélectionnés
francs mais non mais c'est n'importe
quoi girafon évidemment pas tolérer
bruxelles avait déjà les transgenres
lancé mais non mais pas du tout non mais
non mais voilà et et le problème c'est
que mes travaux tient boncourt qui a
s'entend avec des moeurs il ya cent ans
et qu'aujourd'hui on aime bien dire que
toutes les femmes sont belles et si on
en croit le règlement nice france aucune
femme n'est belle il faut avoir moins de
25 ans pour faire connaître 65 ans
célibataire faut pas avoir fait de
photos de charme aux parents de peer 2
peer singh etc etc il ya des personnes
ne s'y retrouve et je ne comprends pas
que la housse les règlements à
l'étranger s'assouplissent on a des
femmes transgenres on a les femmes qui
sont un peu en surpoids etc etc nous on
a un règlement aussi archaïque et aussi
rigides alors il ya une autre question
qui se pose souvent aussi pour le
concours - un gars et les propositions
qui sont faites on voudrait montrer une
image c'est celle de sarah if they car
c'est une étudiante en droit de 20 ans
qui a été la première femme avec un
voile à participer à la finale 2000
sanglots terre regarde
malheureusement je n'ai pas été choisi
en tant que miss angleterre 18 cependant
ça n'a jamais été mon but mon but étant
simplement de montrer que nous sommes
aussi des fleurs outre-mer et je pense
avoir montré en entrant dans le temps de
50 / 20 minutes
un exploit dont j'assurais
tu disais quelque chose tout à l'heure
le fait que pour les filles c'était bien
ça leur donnait confiance moi je me mets
à la place d'une fille qui a 18 ans et
qui n'auraient pas forcément bas par
rapport à certaines qui sont venus me
parler et qui me disent bah moi en fait
quand je regarde ça moi je suis pas fine
comme elle est en fait ça donne pas
confiance à tout le monde ça fait même
se sentir coupables certaines filles qui
correspondent pas à ses critères de
beauté là parce que quand on y réfléchit
c'est quoi la femme élue sur miss france
c'est une femme qui est là qui a moins
de 25 ans c'est une femme qui ne boit
pas qui ne fume pas et je suis désolé
mais il ya quelque chose qui est en
train de se passer en ce moment par
rapport à l'image des femmes et miss
france ne suit pas et quand tu dis que
ça donne ofi le pouvoir de pouvoir se
sentir correctement dans leur corps
c'est pas vrai parce que toutes celles
qui correspondent pas aux critères de
miss france est belle se sentent lésés
et moi je trouve que pour ça le concours
il est ringard t'interviewer toutes les
femmes de france qui correspondent pas
aux critères dément mais j'ai parlant il
ya quand même certaines filles qui
viennent et qui disent oh bah oui
pourquoi est ce que vous mettez ces
travailleurs là moi ça ne fait pas
forcément de sentir bien il ya plein de
filles qui disent mais en fait à tout le
temps montré que des femmes qui sont
maigres et qui ont un physique qui
regarde personne ne fait que personne
n'ait magazines féminins
non mais attendez personne ne parle
d'interdiction mais il ya des magazines
féminins il ya des marques qui met en
valeur des femmes qui correspond
forcément critères et ennemi ce concours
miss ronde le concombre mamie le
concours se sont même à salir le oui
mais jeudi les marques sont en train
d'évoluer les émissions sont en train
d'évoluer les magazines sont en train
d'évoluer mais pas mis france pas miss
france mais miss france évolue avec des
tableaux qui sont différents de ce qu'on
a pu avoir il ya quelques années tu sais
si tu regardes le concours miss france
sur les dernières années tu vois que les
discours sont plus les mêmes tu vois que
l'efficacité sont plus les mêmes et tu
vois que c'est de son allié morphologie
on va les entrepreneuses des donc c'est
arrêter d'avoir mal à la place des gens
quoi non je suis pas en train de te dire
que je me mets à la place je te parle de
filles qui viennent le dire il ya plein
de chic ils sont en train de le dire et
vous dites c'est oui ça évolue
légèrement légèrement mais le message
qui est passé c'est que la femme
parfaite elle rit correspond à ses
critères là alors on dit 90 elle
correspond à 120 si l'on dit que c'est
une femme ce
qui représente une certaine idée de la
france donc voilà donc elle est là elle
à ce critère là et moi ça me gêne pas et
après tu auras miss ronde qui aura
d'autres critères parce qu'à ce moment
là dans ces cas là l'élection de miss
ronde tu auras défis qui seront une
forme qui diront je me sens moi viens
discriminer ce que j'ai pas droit à tant
le fait que miss monde existait ce que
c'est pas un problème en soi parce que
si jamais été miss france n'est pas
ronde par contre si jamais theron alors
elles sont justement ces salles qui
tient pas on obligé de créer des
concours des bills uniquement parce que
miss france est pas capable de s'adapter
à quoi ressemble véritablement les
françaises c'est tout alors justement
parce qu'il ya une vidéo qui a fait
énormément parler aussi sur la
grossophobie d'une ancienne miss qui a
dit qu'elle ait enfin une miss qui
n'avait pas été sélectionné pour être
miss france alors qu'elle dit part même
si j'ai un petit peu de dettes qu'ils
ont plus pourquoi je fais pas le
concours miss france pourquoi je
corresponds pas que m critères ont
regardé a été envoyé un message sur
facebook pour me dire écoute amandine tu
as tout à fait ta place tu viens donc
j'ai fait l'élection au mois de mai 2000
volcans d'auvergne où j'ai été super
bien accueilli et c'est là où on m'a dit
bon écoute essaye de faire ton possible
pour entrer dans une taille 38 40
en fait on m'a clairement dit abete a
une très jolie était très jolie tête
mais le corps ne passe pas je suis l'une
des premières à ouvrir ma bouche en fait
et etcetc beaucoup de personnes qui
souffrent de ça moi j'ai 24 ans je pense
que j'ai un minimum quand même la tête
sur les épaules et j'ai un petit peu de
recul sur les choses ça aurait été une
gamine de 18 ans on lui dit est très
belle mais t'es trop grosse et vous vous
imaginez les conséquences un match que
j'aurais la barre
la juge moi vous y est incroyable qu'on
vous ait dit ça comme ça aussi c'est
chez toi
je regarde jamais cette émission
sympa oui j'y vais répondre à louis il
ya un gros changement quand même c'est
qu'aujourd'hui tous ces bugs tous ces
scandales toutes ces injustices et bien
on les entend elles sortent sur les
plateaux de télé et miss france essaie
d'y remédier aujourd'hui moi je suis le
premier à être vigilant là dessus sur la
diversité la représentation de toutes
les régions il ya énormément de femmes
de la diversité qui sont maintenant dans
les concours dans les castings donc ça
c'est des evaux ferais-tu la première
mais miss de couleurs surtout 93
seulement des comptes ou pas regardez
regardez j'ai l'image regarder miss
france
miss
oualalou sport
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah oui véronique de la cruz en 93
seulement oui c'est parti très tard mais
ça commence à évoluer il ya eu des
scandales on le sait mais aujourd'hui je
trouve qu'il ya une prise en compte
différentes à l'intérieur de miss france
de ce qu'est la france d'aujourd'hui